what are the solutions that globalists
come up with do they come up with
solutions that free more people that
help you figure out you know or help
create the conditions so that you can
live your life as you see fit is that
what they're interested in doing are
they interested in say spreading
capitalism which of course is the idea
that we can all together rise together
because of competition and human
Ingenuity and individual thought and all
of that stuff is is it that what they're
pushing on us or is it always about
taking something away whether that's
your ability to go outside or your right
to Medical privacy or perhaps even to
cook on a simple gas stove gas stoves
could soon get 86 from kitchens across
the country going forward the U.S
consumer product safety commissioner is
considering a ban on the appliances for
new builds it says those appliances can
be a source of indoor pollution
sometimes linked to Childhood asthma but
also the gas no gas lines and new
construction is that about fossil fuels
or is it about
sorry I'm getting in trouble no well no
that's that's a short answer it's about
climate change because methane is 80
times more powerful than CO2 when it
comes to heating up the planet so big
time but but in small spaces it's
personal health okay it is an incredible
moment that happened there on CNN you
know I've often talked to you guys about
how so I have a thing in my ear when I
do this show it's not because anyone's
talking to me or telling me what to do
it's so that when we play those videos
so that we don't get feedback I can
actually hear the video so as you're
watching them live I can hear them
through here now she the host of CNN
over there she's getting information as
she's talking right they're telling her
what to say they're or they're telling
her not what to say she was getting in
trouble or is it about
sorry I'm getting in trouble what what
also the fact that CNN is now doing
stories on the problems with gas stoves
it's funny they weren't doing it last
week but suddenly the Democrats and the
Machine want to go after your gas stove
so now CNN starts telling you about all
the problems with gas stoves I want to
be very clear you [ __ ] are
sorry Kristen now we're getting
demonetized I did it no lunch for
anybody uh you're you're never coming
from my gas stove when we moved here to
Florida the street that I live on does
not have uh natural gas to each of the
houses so we had an electric stove here
David is a great chef I talked about
this yesterday I've gotten actually
pretty good myself I really enjoy
cooking now and cooking on an electric
stove is not fun it is mechanical and
Technical there's no fuel for it that's
why no Chef go to any restaurant any
great restaurant go to any mediocre
restaurant basically go to any
restaurant on Earth and they're cooking
with fire you know people have been
cooking for fire for a long time the
cavemen it was a long time ago they were
cooking with fire fire good it okay uh
you are not coming the first thing we
did was uh we removed that electric
thing we tried to figure out if there
was a way to do something like crazy
crazy thing to get gas to the house
couldn't do that but we got propane
buried a tank outside and now we have
fire and that's what we're cooking with
and you ain't coming for it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]